it's 9 54 p.m a young woman is working
out in the gym at her apartment complex
she is all alone then a guy knocks on
the door it was just another Jew coming
in to work out so I didn't mind I didn't
think of anything out of that 24 year
old nishali AMA opens the door for him
then she goes back to her workout three
minutes later it happens he approaches
and tries to grab her by the waist as
soon as he was approaching me I pushed
him I said bro get away from me and he
kept trying to come towards me and kept
reapproaching me so to the point where I
just ran off to the side of it like
there was a gym bench and I went to call
9-1-1 at that moment and that's where he
started trying to grab my phone and I
threatened him like bro get away from me
stop trying to touch me and he started
chasing me around the bench she's chased
to the other side of the gym a struggle
ensues and nishali is wrestled to the
floor when it was happening I actually
had no fear I am a bodybuilder and I'm
actually pretty strong so in my mind I
knew knew I was Stronger than him and I
knew I could fight back wow did he ever
mess with the wrong woman
her social media is filled with her
amazing Feats of Strength
sure enough he's exhausted you can see
him trying to catch his breath at the
end of the video you can see him getting
tired as if I keep going if I keep
pushing I keep fighting he's going to
stop he's going to let go and he finally
did okay I'm sorry as [__] up as it is
what's really weird is how he's just
walking after her
isn't that like oh man like hold up hold
up shout out to her she did her thing
but he jumps on her initially and she
runs right and might have him like why
don't you just run out the front door
the door that they came in but the one
that she ran in at the end
and since she ran deeper into the gym
where I guess it's a closed off area
somebody but you know you panic you make
the wrong decision what's really weird
is this dude's just walking for like the
Terminator people say she fought him off
and and and all the stuff but because
you just stopped
am I crazy no you're not crazy but the
thing that happened is that in these
situations as well is
none of this is rational yeah sure none
none of this the guy acting is rational
sure because you see situations where
people try to rob a store and they get
caught you watch the way they book out
the door they're scrambling falling
breaking everything to get out right you
see like people who are about to die
dude this dude's just like it's weird
come here you know it's not weird the
assailant Xavier Thomas Jones was
arrested the next day turns out he lives
in the building in Tampa and nishali is
being hailed for her display of True
Grit as long as you don't give up you
fight back you show him that you are
strong that you are one that you're able
to fight back and survive this and get
out of the situation I believe it's
possible well first thing first ladies
don't take no uh online courses about uh
self-defense and stuff like that all
that [__] is bogus and it's really just
more harmful than anything okay all the
thing I have to do is this and then this
and that's all [__] it's crap scrap
that in the garbage the best thing for
anybody man woman whatever
martial art classes you take those
classes and then you realize how much
you cannot fight okay that's the reason
why so you're not gonna go out and do
nothing to nobody and I keep fighting
thing
yeah that she did the proper thing and
shout outs to you my girl you did you
did you did that as far as this dude
it's a whole last Square though I can't
there's a first person like yo fight
with everything you got yeah but just
understand like you're working at a
disadvantage she did nothing wrong in
this whole thing her opening the door is
not weird no some people like why would
you open the door the dude lives in the
building she seen him at the gym before
that's being a decent person but you're
gonna not open the door gym door to
somebody who's in the building who
you've seen there before I think she did
nothing wrong she didn't do nothing
wrong she fought listen who cares maybe
she didn't run out the door right away
when you're panicking like things like
that happen you can't expect everybody
to keep they cool and make the most
logical decision in a crisis mode people
don't act like people don't understand
how much whenever there's a situation
that happens yeah you first trying to
understand what the [__] is going on
what does he want he's coming at me and
you're like wait what do you want before
you run out the door yeah so of course
you didn't run right right away but
whatever all right well listen and so
yeah the whole fighting thing
um
I'm gonna be honest with you
she a fighter but she lucky
if this dude was really trying trying
she's not getting away you saw the way
you got up in the place he Ragdoll he
lift her up and slammed her right down
if a man was really trying
and that's that's a reality so that's
why I tell people like all right listen
in a world with this many criminals if
you live in a place that's that
dangerous delays hey get strapped up if
you can I I know women who tell me they
carry it they put they keep it in their
purse they keep it on them Yo listen the
most vulnerable are the ones you need
the most access to these firearms
because you're not fighting on equal
footing all this talk about she said I'm
a bodybuilder so that me that don't mean
[__] [__] in a fighting situation if
that dude had any grappling skills and
just put her in a truck hold she's done
he had her back the whole time he could
have wrapped her up and put her
unconscious in a minute or less she
ain't doing no screaming with somebody
putting [__] pressure on her that's
not happening
she's fortunate in that regard and I'm
happy for her she fought she did what
she needed to do great but just
understand she ain't the only woman who
fights there's plenty other women fight
and they end up with broken faces and
broken bodies that don't mean I'm saying
not to fight I'm just saying
get whatever tools you need to level the
playing field
pepper spray super effective if you got
it on you and you know how to use it
great Firearms even better and I know
there's gonna be a bunch of people in
the comments like are you saying because
if you live in a dangerous [__] place
yeah if you're living in a place that
allows it
get it absolutely
that's all I got whatever they allow
whatever they allow whether it be pepper
spray whatever whistle you [__] got
you'd be surprised how a lot of these
tools will change the whole dynamic you
get mugged and you got one of these
things that make loud noises that
terrifies most criminals because they
don't want the attention did you see the
video of the dude trying to rob a car
place and the guy comes in with like and
he struggles with his aunt and it was
with his gun yeah
by the time you do a dealership yeah
he's like he's gonna buy a car yeah so
they go back behind yeah and it was
crazy yeah he's not behind the desk to
go and get the paperwork the dude you
see the guy who's falling behind who
wants to buy the car trying to get the
gun out before he can even do it the guy
wasn't even reaching for paperwork he
was suspicious yeah so you pulled out
his gun and he was like oh my bad yeah
and he left like
you have to know how to manage the
firearm you have to know to unload in
all the [__] procedures that come
with it definitely yeah you ask me what
I think she lucky
was maybe he's not with somebody oh [__]
here she lucky
that's what she is I don't care how much
she's squatting if a dude really want to
go at it that dude wasn't big he wasn't
strong he wasn't a huge lifter and he
ragged all her and it's not even that
there's weights around
he could regret if he grabs a weight
and her of that thing to her head it's
done though what if he had a weapon an
actual weapon you know what I mean in a
place that actually allows for it what
if he just rolled up on her pulled the
cat out and said strip what's she gonna
do you don't even have to have a gun if
he had if he had a knife on him yup [__]
a gun if he had the only equalizer in no
situation slap
so appendix does it
so listen I'm glad that she's safe and
I'm glad things are okay and things
ended well but you have to understand
for every story that ends up like this
there's dozens more that end up the
other way where she gets beaten up to a
pulp where she loses her life or when
worse things happen so that's why I
advocate ladies listen
men and women they're different
they are so whatever you got to do to
even that playing field I support it
um and I want y'all to be safe in that
regard so that's what I would say don't
ask us what we think that's calling
someone said well you should teach men
not to do this what makes you think I've
been teaching anybody to do these kinds
of things but the truth of the world is
there's going to be women who lie about
being raped and there's going to be men
who are going to commit crimes
regardless there's gonna be women who
are going to commit crop crimes you
can't stop that so if you understand
that portion next thing you could do is
to defend yourself as best as possible
let's teach men not to do that that's
not how life works yeah I teach you guys
not to steal cars but you still lock
your door don't you
like that's not how life works I'm gonna
do what I can and I'm gonna do what I
can and what I can actually I'm gonna do
what I what is possible for me to do
teaching everyone that you shouldn't do
that and making sure they all not do
that that's not a thing teaching is not
the problem here yep okay so I'm gonna
to be able to do what I can
and if it's trap up well
I'm a strap up yeah
so anyways listen what you guys think in
the comments below did you